a few days ago a new experiment was
released yes yes
we can now use AI to tell a consistent
cohesive story and I'm going to try
doing that
[Music]
big thanks to Capital One shopping for
sponsoring a portion of this video you
know here at Corridor we like to joke
that you know technology is moving so
fast in a few years you just need to
snap a few pictures of your friends with
your phone and generate a whole movie
with them starring in it right and
that's what we say to ourselves when
it's 3 A.M and we're sitting there
grinding out rotoscoping and trying to
match our 3D models to our backgrounds
and it all just seems like a fantasy
that's so far away but a few days ago
something new came out and it's gonna
change all of this this year AI image
generators burst onto the scene and I've
become obsessed with the tech I can't
stop thinking about it I think it's
going to Forever change entertainment
filmmaking art visual effects but
there's been one big problem that all
these generators have there's no way for
you to add knowledge to these AI image
generators so you can't add like your
dog or your friend or how about like a
fictional character that you invented or
how about yourself right nope it's
impossible well a few days ago a new
experiment was released to try and fix
this very problem and because the final
Folks at Puget have built us a computer
capable of the burden of AI computation
we can actually run this experiment
we're going to see if we can solve this
problem Sam we're gonna make history
okay you ready sweet all right I'm going
to put you into the computer okay
open up that computer man I'll fit so
the first thing we got to do I gotta
take like five to ten pictures of you
I'm like a deep fake or I need like
thousands last time I tried to steal
someone's likeness with AI I had to sift
through nine hours of podcast footage so
this is so far a breeze yeah so now I'm
going to run these pictures of Sam
through dream Booth which is actually
free on GitHub if you want to download
it and mess with it dreambooth fix is a
problem with AI image generators the way
this stuff generally works is this
machine learning algorithm is going to
associate visual patterns and forms with
words if I type in Black Cat what's
happening is It's associated the color
that we identify as black with the word
black is associating the forms that we
identify as a cat with the word cat it's
kind of bringing those two together when
you type in Black Cat now the problem is
if I want to do say a picture of Sam the
AI model has never seen Sam it has no
knowledge of Sam and if I try to
describe Sam like if I say bearded dude
then I just get a bunch of random
pictures of beer to do so it's not the
same guy every time there's no way to
have the same person every time
dreambooth fixes this by letting us add
new knowledge to this model and having
it be consistent knowledge and it does
so in a way that doesn't screw up all
the knowledge that's already there I
didn't realize it was so complicated by
adding more data to the model it risks
the stability of the entire thing yeah
that's crazy once we have this all
trained we can now generate pictures of
Sam so let's make a photo of Sam Gorski
laughing oh wow oh
that's crazy that's a deep that's a deep
laugh I can hear it
okay obviously we wanted to see a
picture of me we could look at the
reference pictures you took but
obviously we have more power than just
creating a simple photo I want to be in
put me in Step Brothers which brother do
you want to be uh John C Riley
it is like me and Johnson Riley had a
baby
movie still of Sam Gorski as Morpheus
from The Matrix 1999. there we go now
I'm starting to get vibes yeah
definitely start to get vibes here all
right movie still of Sam Gorski as
Batman I'm on
[Laughter]
freaking thick Batman
's huge Batman thick Batman was he so
thick there we go there it is I love how
it it's just your chin it's smart enough
to just put your chin in there yeah I
mean it's yeah it's Batman with like a
little bit of a beard poking out but I'm
not like I'm not blown away yet it's
like just photoshopping a little bit of
chin hair onto Batman you know like it's
not transformative maybe we could go a
little weirder with this maybe yeah what
do you want to see can we just do
uncanny valley Sam
oh there we go there we go uncanny
valley Sam it's like well modeled
clearly some craftsmanship went into
that 3D model of me but it looks really
weird I just want to see something
stylized you know I want to see
something unique and stylized who's the
best digital artist in the world uh
grandkowski yeah
he's clearly one of the top of digital
artists to ever live so it should be in
his style let's insert me into this oh
there we go yes so it works it turns out
it works this whole time it hasn't been
working it actually works great oh how
about this uh digital painting of the
God of War same horsey face
yeah I told you wow I did it I knew that
wow that's crazy that's great that's
awesome but hold on a digital painting
of Commander price from Call of Duty Sam
Gorski
it knew maybe super grizzled I love it I
hope I hope I look like that one day all
right so here we go got we have some
momentum here
Lego's the one oh Lego
yep done done literally just first
moving on yeah oh I got a weird one for
you GTA San Andreas screenshot
these are first results half the time
too we gotta do old snake big boss from
metal gear solid wood
he is a trailblazer we are going to take
his soul now
oh my God
wow yes yes
yeah dude isn't that so sweet Yoji
wherever you are man holy [ __ ] yourself
thank you dude hold on is that saved
it's saved that's my profile picture now
hey you know what let's let's switch it
over to me I also have the training
model of myself
yeah looking cool thank you Sam no
problem thank you Sam no problem you
know you look great as big boss too that
was really good that was really really
really really really good you know what
maybe I'm really changing my mind about
posole I think previously I said like
look I don't want an Apple Watch I don't
want Facebook to read my Biometrics and
change that into AI generated content in
order to you know make ad money off of
me but if it does what this is doing
I might be all in so one thing that's
worth noting I took a bunch of pictures
of Sam with his camo jacket on and took
some pictures of him with a black shirt
on and a lot of these pictures Sam has
the camo jacket on so for the first time
ever we can now create consistent
characters which is honestly historic
meaning we can now use AI to tell a
consistent cohesive story and I'm going
to try doing that
AI Art's really cool like oh oh hold up
hey who's that it's Jake
Hey Jake hey so I
so you are uh neck deep in generating
some amazing art right now right yeah
it's super cool man you should see these
awesome renders we're making I also have
a tool that's going to be amazing and
make life a lot easier it's a huge
thanks to Capital One shopping for
sponsoring this portion of the video
Forget digging for coupon codes that
don't work and searching endlessly for
deals without results okay guys the free
Capital One Shopping browser extension
instantly searches available coupons and
automatically applies them to your cart
across thousands of sites dude I love it
when I got a coupon code that saves me
money it's very satisfying you might
think hey
it's got to be a card holder in order
for this browser extension to work no
not true you actually don't have to be a
Capital One card holder to get these
benefits maybe we can try one like
experiencing benefits yeah Sam Gorski
experiencing incredible savings and here
we have it I like where this is going
well imagine you're shopping on say
Amazon right toothbrushes on Amazon well
what the Capital One shopping experience
does is it automatically goes out and
sees if there's other available prices
that are cheaper than what you're
currently paying and it helps you find
those deals cheaper on than Amazon
that's a thing
yes whoa guys I think we've hit the nail
on the head here and I think we all
understand if you want to get better
deals as you shop online all you need to
do is sign up for the free Capital One
Shopping browser extension and you'll
start saving it instantly so I'm going
to click the link in the description
below and if you're interested
Link in the description below too and
get started today just just click the
link in the description below and a huge
thanks once again to Capital One
shopping for sponsoring this portion of
the video now let's get back to what
other crazy ideas we can come up with
using these tools I can't get over how
cool Sam looks when I say like Sam
Gorski Evo wizard the way the image
comes out just nearly makes me think of
a character and story like okay I
probably had his hand cut off in the uh
the battle with between you know men and
orc 20 years ago but now he's been
delving into magic in the hopes of
bringing it back because he's getting
into necromancy like it just I just go
right I can just look at these pictures
and I can just say generally generate
generate and make a new one every time I
want to try telling a story so I'm going
to go through the office I'm going to
capture a bunch of people's likeness in
my AI Pokeball and I'm going to put them
into the system and I'm going to
generate this crazy Epic Fantasy tale
now I'm going to inspire them when
they've seen these characters the same
way I'm feeling inspired I mean blow
their minds
all right
thank you for joining me for story time
[Applause]
Cutting Edge technology to weave you
guys into a tale that I'm about to tell
so without further Ado ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the kingdom of
larion the hustling and bustling place
with Happy People ruled by the kind and
benevolent
I made it everybody so King Matthew he's
always thinking about what's best for
his people but it's hard being a king
making the hard decisions because you
see King Matthew is troubled
[Applause]
[Music]
he's got the dread pirate Christians
sailing the Seas blockading his porch
[Applause]
he doesn't just have Pirates he has
sleazy merchants
he's got the church converting his
people corrupting them King Matthew
thinks Ponders you know Kings by
definition there's only one of them all
alone somber thinking and then one day
one day a dark Man shows up promising
King Matthew to alleviate all his
troubles
that's your friend dude are you so dark
the kingdom can be ruled his enemies can
be dealt with Matthew becomes the
jealous mean evil King and together they
start ruling the kingdom with an iron
fist hell yeah before you see the dark
magic they talked about is fireman look
at that here dealing away with their
enemies casting the church down burning
your enemies one by one oh wow
Matthew sits upon his fire Throne the
kingdom struggles is it going to crumple
and fall people under their oppressor
the people need a hero they need
a champion
[Applause]
that's crazy that's perfect Jordan the
brave knight fought many wars always for
good never for evil dude this just makes
me ashamed of who I really am
Jordan the night here's Tales of this
dark sorcerer that has infected the mind
of King Matthew and is therefore
bringing the kingdom down
yes look AI can't drill hands all right
so just ignore the hands and he
confronts them he tells him that he
needs to be banished from these lands he
needs to go otherwise he will kill him
himself by his sword of course Sam the
fire sources like mere mortals you mean
nothing he fires up his magic surrounds
himself in Flames as Jordan the Knight
stares him down he thinks back to the
one bit of advice the one item he got
it's going to make all the difference in
this battle before on his way into town
he stopped at a Tavern where he made a
gnome
foreign
[Laughter]
[Applause]
ER has a very special item which is a
sword forged from a meteorite and that
sword always blows red hot you can
strike down anyone including the most
magical of Mages and so he gives that
sword to Jordan the knife and tells him
to be careful with it because it might
be his downfall so Samwise the fire Rage
he is casting his fire spells preparing
the destroy his enemy Jordan pulls out
the meteorite sword which blows red hot
and charges in for the fight but Sam
wise is slinging Fireballs left and
right and Jordan's no match for the
magic
[Music]
as the light Fades and everything goes
black Jordan the night sees a vision a
vision of a man and a white cloak
approaching
and as we painted onto the side of the
building wow oh my God perhaps a former
Emperor the spirit of the former Emperor
or the founder of this land he comes to
Jordan in a vision and he grants them
the feather of life and he brings him
back and Jordan the knights brings up
4-0 ready to fight
take him down Jordan and he charges and
he causes horses leaps over the flames
slice and found sandwich the fire Mage
casting him off the walls of the castle
and into the water
again you know this is all in a day's
work for Jordan the night he's a man who
gives himself every day selflessly for
the kingdom but you know the real
question is what happened to King
Matthew for the evil slipped away from
his mind and he be grew remorseful and
full of regret and he needed to make his
wrongs right and so he gathers all those
people and brings Jordan the knife and
he tells them you know I'm wrong this
man will protect the kingdom forever
more and he gives him many medals and
honors and he will rules but no one king
forever after
and Jordan will be there to protect him
and guide him along the way in the
Kingdom of larian where they lived
happily ever after
[Applause]
Wards
those images are objectively ten times
beyond what I thought was possible yeah
the water detail oh with Sam's shots are
is so incredible so it just looks so
photo real I mean even like the
painterly stuff it just feels so
artistic like it was ahead of human
touch to it this I originally typed a
wizard in Black robes drowning screaming
underwater and then I I don't get Sam
it's just a guy but it was you know it
had the beginnings of Sam but the thing
is when I don't type Sam's name I get
way more flexibility so I can do
something like this because otherwise if
I type in Sam's name it'd be like a head
shot which is what you kind of see for
the other ones it's like I don't include
Sam's name I get a wacky picture but the
guy at least kind of has a beard still
kind of looks like Sam I'm gonna use in
painting and I just select the face and
go make it look like Sam now Matt that's
your new album yeah with a lot more
fingers
a lot more fingers but it gets the level
of my arm hair it's that well it's a
little bit shy yeah it's a little light
on it but still though and let's not
forget
[Laughter]
if there were ever motivation to start
taking steroids
yeah the stuff of like when the hood is
off Sam yeah
Photoshop picture insane the only one I
didn't recognize was finners
the most realistic one
spot
that's so good it's like your face just
totally sunk it into this massive head
Greg Rutkowski everything looks better
when you type Greg Rutkowski
the thing is he's a real artist doing
real work is it our art is it his art
where do we stand there you know I
didn't want to end this video without
talking about these moral implications I
don't have all the answers like we're
literally on the front here here we're
just figuring it out there's certainly a
world where it's okay to pull influences
from other artists and other people we
as human beings we do that all the time
when a piece of software is doing it
when does that become influencing and
when does it become copying I would just
encourage all of you out there if you're
making art and you're using other
people's Inspirations do something to
make it your own don't just type a
picture of Sam by Greg gokowski and then
post it online saying look at my art
because the way this program works is
kind of like going to a giant Library
filled with billions of images and you
finally find the one you're looking for
what are you doing beyond that to make
it your art anyways leave your thoughts
down in the comments below I'd love to
hear what you guys think because this is
certainly a powerful tool it certainly
enables many people to create beautiful
images we're going to figure this all
together so let's do it